What’s actually inside that resupply capsule
going up to the ISS anyway?
Ice cream and snacks?
Or actual science?
Personal effects?
Why not all three?
On June 28th, CRS-7, a SpaceX Falcon 9 rocket
exploded on the way to resupply the International
Space Station.
As of this writing the cause of the explosion
is still unknown; though it might be an overpressure
event in one of the liquid oxygen tanks...
hopefully we'll learn more soon, keep an eye
on DiscoveryNews.com.
But this comes just a few months after Russia's
Progress 59 also failed on the way to the
ISS.
I mean, Scott Kelly is slated to spend a full
year in space, would this mess up those plans?
How long can they last?
I HAVE QUESTIONS.
Firstly, according to NASA administrator Charlie
Bolden, the ISS has enough supplies to last
QUOTE, "several months," with an April presentation
saying they could survive until September
5th with current supplies.
Plus, there is a Russian-flown cargo mission
slated for this Friday, July 3, and a Japanese
flight slated for August, and another SpaceX
flight in September -- so don't get your MAGs
in a bunch about the crew.
The ISS isn't COMPLETELY dependent on us down
here!
The ISS uses Water Reclamation and Oxygen
Generation systems pioneered for submarines.
Water is reclaimed from washing, humidity
condensation, urination and so on, anywhere
they can capture water it's done.
Then they purify it to super-high standards
before recycling it for showers, drinking
water and oxygen generation.
To create oxygen, they run electricity through
the H2O, splitting the hydrogen from the oxygen
molecules and creating O2 in a process called
electrolysis -- boom!
Oxygen (and hydrogen)!
But before you ask those H's are then fed
into the Sabatier System -- which uses a catalyst
to combine the hydrogen and exhaled carbon
dioxide to create H2O and CH4 -- methane.
The water is recycled and the methane is vented
into space.
This can produce about 2 kilos of oxygen per
day, enough for about 2 people with a little
extra -- when more people are up there, they
have pressurized tanks from Earth too…
Of course, that brings us back to the failed
cargo missions.
A Dragon capsule can hold 4000 pounds of cargo
(1800 kg), in the 883 cubic feet of space
(11 m3) -- the cargo capacity of about 6 minivans.
The CRS-7 that exploded contained "materials
to support more than 30 student research investigations
and more than 35 of approximately 250 science
and research
investigations that will occur during Expeditions
44 and 45."
They were sending equipment to examine meteors
entering the atmosphere, Microsoft HoloLenses,
and equipment to prep for deep space exploration
by testing the effects of microgravity on
astronaut Scott Kelly, and the ability to
grow food in space.
The CRS-7 also contained new docking attachments
to expand commercial docking with the ISS,
plus food and other standard resupply mission
materials.
According to government contractor, Lockheed-Martin,
ISS resupply contains hardware, experiments,
food, toothpaste, cleaning supplies, laptops,
printers, you name it.
It's essential to pack these items securely
and with a plan, in case of leakage or failure.
For example, bleach is never packed with cleaner,
because if they leak, the fumes are poisonous.
The Dragon's interior is pressurized and can
hold a variety of NASA cargo bags and freezers
for carrying materials such as biological
samples!
They even shipped Bluebell ice cream up once!
Obviously, in this case, it was a total loss.
Sure, the explosion is a pretty serious situation,
and all SpaceX flights are grounded until
they find the exact cause, but at least no
lives were lost.
As sad as it is; experiments, food, and materials
can be replaced.
The ISS flies at an average altitude of 248
miles (400 kilometers), and it's one of the
most challenging and dangerous road trips
humans regularly undertake.
As Charlie Bolden said in a NASA release on
the CRS-7, "This is a reminder that spaceflight
is an incredible challenge, but we learn from
each success and each setback."
What do you think of all this?
Should we put more money into the space program?
Or are we wasting our time?